el momento de actualizar la información
económica en france 24 en español y nos
acompaña por eso como siempre nuestro
compañero jorge hurtado jorge vamos a
dedicarnos ahora a las economías de las
empresas conocidas como unicornio
contanos de qué se trata y cómo es su
presencia en américa latina así que
bueno cabe mencionar que una empresa
unicornio es aquella que ha sido
evaluada arriba de mil millones de
dólares entre los unicornios más famosos
se encuentran
spacex uber o snap red entre otras pero
en américa latina' el primer unicornio
surgió en 2007 en argentina fue mercado
libre a propósito por más de una década
y luego le siguió la empresa despegar
pero en menos de cuatro años desde 2017
la fecha el número de estar todo
latinoamericana valoradas en más de mil
millones de dólares subió a más de 20
conversamos al respecto con la argentina
silvina moschini ella fue la primera
mujer latinoamericana en fundar una
empresa unicornio con she works y nos
regaló un panorama de los unicornios en
latinoamérica
en américa latina tenemos unicornios que
en general vienen del área de fintech de
tecnología financiera pero también hay
muchos marketplaces y también están
empezando a surgir nuevas categorías
como por ejemplo la categoría de
alimentación con un nuevo unicornio que
surgió desde chile hace aproximadamente
un mes pero que está cambiando un poco
la dinámica de lo que eran
tradicionalmente las compañías de
tecnología que eran las que más rápido
escalaban y más capital recibían para
convertirse un negocio de mil millones
de dólares
bueno una de las grandes características
que tenemos los latinoamericanos es la
creatividad y es también la mirada de
impacto muchos de los unicornios que
están surgiendo en nuestra región
también están creando una nueva ola de
potencial es un y con eso como le dicen
en la industria los únicos la
creatividad como veremos de una región
con muchos desafíos hace una gran
diferencia así que ideas innovadoras
ideas disruptivas nuevas categorías de
mercado son las que están más surgiendo
en nuestra región bueno jorge surge la
siguiente pregunta cómo han crecido las
inversiones para este tipo de compañías
así es el crecimiento ha sido
exponencial en la inyección de capital
de riesgo bueno según la compañía
brasileña sling hub la cantidad de
capital de riesgo total inyectado en la
región pasó de 2.200 millones de dólares
en 2017 a 13 mil 100 millones de dólares
en 2021 de ese dinero la mayoría ha
quedado en brasil que posee más de 17
mil startups seguido de méxico y
colombia- esto en más de 5 mil 175
rondas de inversión entre las 10 startup
que más inversión recibieron siete de
ellas son brasileñas éstas son
consideradas compañías unicornio más
grandes de toda latinoamérica nuestra
invitada es productora de micro hunters
un show que busca democratizar el acceso
a oportunidades de inversión para
personas que quieren ser parte de estas
compañías unicornios y esto dijo sobre
los retos de los emprendedores que
aspiran a tener una de estas compañías
los desafíos de los emprendedores y de
las emprendedoras en particular porque
notita a parte de las mujeres tiene un
enorme desafío en levantar capital mucho
mayor que los emprendedores hombres
solamente el 2% del capital va a las
mujeres y tienen que ver con esto
precisamente el acceso a capital en el
volumen capital significativo para poder
escalar los negocios muchas de las
compañías mueren lo que se llama el
valle de la muerte que es ese periodo
donde las compañías reciben capital
prueba en su modelo pero luego no pueden
o en escalar pero también otra de las
cosas que siempre digo los emprendedores
necesitábamos dinero y también
necesitamos acceso a redes los negocios
son un deporte de contacto y necesitamos
empresas personas organizaciones que nos
sponsor en y que nos permitan conectar
los puntos entre las soluciones que
traemos al mercado y los canales de
distribución o aquellos que necesitan
estas soluciones para sus problemas
porque entonces esto significaría que
hay muchísimas oportunidades en esta
región para acabar el emprendimiento
todos definitivamente eso nos dicen los
números cada vez que escuchamos más de
nuevas empresas unicornios en la región
pero detrás hay un capital humano
dispuesto a innovar y generar impacto
así como valor en los negocios al
respecto nuestra invitada selvin amos y
me dejó un par de consejos para quienes
están en esta aventura de emprender
pensar en grande que hoy estamos
viviendo la época perfecta para la
transformación digital y la creación de
compañías exponenciales compañías que
pueden ser 10 x 10 veces más grandes que
lo que son las compañías tradicionales y
el mercado hoy está listo para poder
recibir sus propuestas transformadoras
porque como decíamos la escasez trae
claridad de mente y esa es la crisis
donde surgen las mejores oportunidades
para cambiar el mundo bueno jorge
interesante hicimos este tema de las
compañías unicornios muchísimas gracias
por esta crónica hasta aquí la
información económica en france 24 sigan
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france 24 punto com
[Música]
i